a 97 year old u.s army veteran is in
italy this morning celebrating his
greatest triumph of world war ii martin
adler is his name he was a 20 year old
private first class when he changed the
lives of three young italians when he
didn't do something chris lipsey is in
northern italy just outside bologna with
a remarkable story of fate and salvation
chris good morning
well good morning from montereyencio a
small village where during world war ii
an american gi came within a sliver of
killing three children by mistake well
now nearly eight decades later a
photograph and a daughter's love have
brought them back together
a reunion 77 years in the making and
three lifetimes nearly cut short in 1944
private first class martin adler was 20
years old stationed in italy and hunting
for nazis
and i had my
good old thompson machine submachine gun
one day in this village and in this
house he noticed movement beneath a pile
of blankets his finger was on the
trigger the safety was off but fate
intervened
mama came out screaming bambini's
bambinis bambinis
children
children
and she stood in front of my gun
preventing me from
in his relief adler had his picture
taken with the siblings bruno mafalda
and julianna and gave them chocolate
just like he did on his return
a miracle says the 97 year old now
living in florida thanks to his daughter
rochelle who was trying to cheer up her
dad during covet lockdown when she and
an italian historian tracked down the
children online mateo called me up and
he said are you sitting down
and they were found in three days it was
just
amazing
we landed here when are we getting off
when are we getting off when are we
getting off and then he just lit up
just seeing the kids
kids now grandparents even great
grandparents just like private adler and
thanks to private adler who didn't pull
the trigger me my children grandchildren
great grandchildren we wouldn't be here
if he hadn't hesitated says bruno naldi
now 83. what do you think that was that
made you stop
god looked down on me and god looked
down on italia
even more remarkable when you consider
private adler says he never hesitated to
pull the trigger if you did you were
dead now today he says he still has
nightmares from the war but when he does
he just looks at that photograph and
they go away anthony chris livesay in
italy thank you chris
yeah but you could see the desperation
of a mother coming out there and yeah my
babies are babies babies babies well and
congratulations to the daughter who went
out and looked and found the three kids
all alive all alive it only took three
days
one of them's a great grandparent now oh
my goodness all right